what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with infinite frontier now um i
do want to say thank you to you guys
there are a couple of you guys out there
who are like actually rob you like you
you've kind of forgotten what had gone
on in dc comics which makes sense
because it's been years since it
happened and it took years for it to
actually happen so i guess it does kind
of make sense i don't know what it is
there seem to be people in my audience
and my fan base who love to get angry
whenever i'm wrong about something like
like i can never be wrong i mean you can
you can believe in that level of
pressure i don't
[Laughter]
i am human i am willing to forgive
myself for being wrong even if you're
not but uh here's the thing right what
this does is it initially picks up
basically with cameron chase showing up
on the doorstep of what's basically the
hall of justice right now one of the
things to remember is that cameron chase
basically works alongside uh you know mr
bones as part of the kind of paranormal
organization that exists out there to
monitor superhero affairs that kind of a
thing because they're kind of looking at
what's going on with regards to this
greater understanding of like the
multiverse and it's it's death and
rebirth and all the stuff that happened
at the end of scott snyder's run
regarding the batman who laughed right
like the the end of what was in effect
an unofficial crisis event i mean let's
call it that right i mean it wasn't
officially a crisis event but it
basically was i mean the defining factor
of a crisis at least at this point in
time anything that affects the
multiverse insofar as its death and
rebirth can largely just be considered a
crisis and that's it right so that's
effectively what it was even if it
wasn't necessarily called that i think
for the most part we can all kind of
agree that was the case which is why you
see a lot of people asking the question
it's been like a year and we already
have another crisis event happening
right it's it's it's dc's panic button
our sales going poorly crisis and that's
basically it
that's that's that's
dc schtick it's been that way since the
original event back in the 1980s with
george perez and marv wolfman now where
cameron chase comes here looking for
answers from both superman and batman
the reality is that she doesn't really
get them and it's one of those
interesting questions that's kind of
asked here and in fact it's an aspect of
the the last crisis event and really
just the overarching dark multiverse
storyline that we never really got an
answer to because she asked the question
okay so like basically earth was
essentially conquered by the batman who
laughs who's just a really twisted evil
version of batman from some other other
reality somewhere because she generally
understands the idea of the dark
multiverse but doesn't fully understand
how deep it goes and so she asked the
question like how long is it before we
have to worry about some version of
yourself like that showing up here now
we kind of got that to a degree when it
came to forever evil right with like the
crime syndicate from earth 3 invading
the dc universe so we kind of got that
but of course that was nowhere near on
the same level as like the whole batman
who laughs saga right the dark dark
multiverse saga wasn't anywhere near
that level of insanity and really world
ending catastrophe and so as a result of
that it's a legitimate question because
one of the things that we never really
got we kind of saw them but we never
really got an instance where we got to
see like the dark multiverse versions of
superman i still say to this day it was
a colossal screw up by dc not to expand
on that more than they did i mean we
kind of got tails from the dark
multiverse but the reality here is at
that point i think it's a little too
late now but at that point in time they
could have cranked out they could have
done it like they did with 52 right like
a new comic every week like just a new
tales from the dark multiverse every
single week and just do it for 52 weeks
i mean it'd be a massive undertaking and
it would take more planning than dc has
going on at the moment right now but
like it's still like it would have been
a great concept but it is a legitimate
question here in terms of whether or not
they need to concern themselves with
some dark evil version of superman
showing up here now one of the things to
know is that while this does seem like a
pretty basic story going on right now
it's in it's huge in terms of what's
going on it's massive in scale of course
you have superman and batman who
basically end up taking off and then of
course cameron chase is left there she
tells bones like okay like they
obviously know more than they're letting
on but that's when she's told okay so
like there's someone that we need to
recruit to our side for the challenges
ahead they have a lot of experience with
time and space manipulations and that's
when we find out she's basically being
told go recruit captain adam now for
those people out there who are familiar
with captain adam that guy is op captain
adam is ridiculously powerful i mean at
his peak this guy's power dwarfed the
power of superman for example one of the
things he can do is he can manipulate
like quantum energy so basically he can
manipulate energy to an infinite level
for an infinite amount of effects like
he can basically do anything he wants to
now granted this is within the scale of
dc comics so while we've never seen him
do anything like what the marquee of
death did where he was like wiping out
whole universes or something like that
the fact is that could potentially
happen there have been alternate reality
stories where adam has done crazy feats
like that where he's just like this huge
multiversal source of energy but you
don't really see him do it all that
often if at all in the main dc landscape
the result of this is that what we end
up doing is again basically picking up
with thomas wayne now this is one of the
things that i do want to explain because
this is something that i happen to think
about as i was recording this and again
one of you guys pointed out alan scott
so we'll talk about that whole thing
here in a second but with thomas wayne
one of the things to remember is that
thomas wayne had in effect made it out
of the flashpoint universe so if you
guys recall tom king's batman run which
was very divisive i enjoyed it there
were people who didn't
and they were very very vocal about the
fact that they didn't really enjoy it um
that during tom king's run uh that what
we had found out is that thomas wayne
had actually been saved from the
flashpoint universe by eobard thaw now
this was one of those divisive moments
from tom king's run because the
significance of thomas wayne and the
fact that he presumably died with this
universe actually happened during the
button storyline right it was kind of
like the last ride of thomas wayne just
going out in like this amazing moment
right he's like what is it like when the
universe is collapsing because of
presumably dr manhattan and all that
kind of stuff that one of the things he
tells bruce wayne is like you like you
know what we do like like wayne's like
whenever wayne's fall like we rise and
he just goes running towards his own
oblivion and that was basically it like
it was a great way to send off the
character and so a lot of fans were kind
of like that's just a perfect ending for
thomas wayne right that's exactly the
way thomas wayne would have gone out the
way he was written in flashpoint that
kind of a thing perfect for his
character when he had shown up in the
the events of tom king's run from the
wedding going forward a lot of people
were wondering okay like why is he here
and how is he here and we ended up
finding out that he was basically saved
from the flashpoint universe by eobard
thon but that his arrival here was more
to basically persuade bruce wayne to
leave the batman mantle behind to allow
him to take over the batman mantle
instead and for bruce to go and live his
life and to be happy with selena kyle
right with catwoman that was one of the
other things that was divisive is
because people were like no bruce wayne
needs to stay batman like we need a
story where you have batman like the cat
in the bat and they keep doing their
thing but like thomas wayne doesn't need
to be a part of this equation it's one
of the things that people were sort of
were really really frustrated about and
so ultimately you ended up having a
scenario where thomas wayne turned
against bane shot him in the head left
him in a coma that concluded the i am
bain arc of of the whole uh tom king run
and then you basically had an instance
where where thomas wayne tried to
convince bruce to basically bail fight
broke out of course thomas wayne was
injured and then was recovering in a
hospital where bruce wayne continued on
and did his own thing and then catwoman
bailed on him and again there were some
very divisive moments in that story
right so a lot of people were just kind
of like like
you know either you love tom king's run
or you hate tom king's run there is no
in between but that's how thomas wayne
is here so he wasn't just arbitrarily
plucked out of his universe but i felt
like that was something that needed to
be explained because i didn't do a good
job of handling that in the last video
that we did so just wanted to throw that
out there but in effect you know what
he's basically told or at least what
what seems to go on here is that
harbinger keeping in mind harbinger was
originally a character and the original
crisis on defended earth but she's
really more like an ai now for the the
multiversal justice league then what you
end up getting is basically president
superman communicating with harbinger
talking to harbinger and ultimately
harbinger says like we've located a
fragment of the ship that thomas wayne
crash landed on where he had just kind
of been taken like literally taken from
the hospital woke up in this ship and
then crash-landed and he has no real
idea how anything transpired or how it
was that he got here he just simply
knows that he's here that what it does
is it basically leads to him just kind
of stepping up or at least it leads to
president superman saying i will go
investigate because the location of this
place is earth 22. now earth 22 was one
of the universes that basically remained
unchanged following well really just its
reintroduction right like one of the
things to remember is that when it comes
to the differing crisis events in dc
comics crisis on infinite earth got rid
of the multiverse infinite crisis
brought it back and then final crisis
made the heroes aware of the fact that
the multiverse had returned earth 22 was
one of those universes that was
explained or at least revealed to us
during grant morrison's multiversity
again the the template that was used for
like the multiverse in the new 52 but a
lot of you guys may be for more familiar
with earth 22 as being the kingdom come
universe which by the way i've been
considering remastering that story
because we did it years ago back when i
hated the kind of videos that i made so
uh if you guys are interested in me
remastering kingdom come if for no other
reason than to know what universe
they're they're referring to and the
events that unfolded in it let me know
right because kingdom come is still
probably one of like the top five best
stories ever written in the history of
dc comics it's phenomenal it's just an
amazing story on my end uh but when when
the arrival takes place right when
thomas wayne and president superman
arrive at earth 22 and things start to
pop off that they're basically met by
the arrival of a person they've never
seen before well that's kind of an
incorrect statement president superman
basically knows who this guy is thomas
wayne doesn't know who this guy is but
president superman says like this is
magog like he was supposed to have been
reformed but all those changes appear to
have been undone so again kind of dc
modifying things now for those of you
guys who aren't familiar with that magog
was a huge player in the the original
kingdom come story the way that story
played out is that basically you had the
joker who just went to the daily planet
massacred everybody and so unlike
injustice where like superman killed him
that what ended up happening is the
joker was essentially put on trial but
magog ended up showing up and killing
the joker and instead of people like
condemning his actions as a vigilante
they celebrated his actions this
disheartened superman and he essentially
walked away from superhero antics this
along with a handful of other events
basically led to the traditional justice
league roster effectively stepping down
and what it did is it left the landscape
open for all these vigilante heroes to
start showing up now the thing about
this is that humanity at the time in the
kingdom come story and a lot of ways saw
the justice league as being incapable
right the joker getting out escaping
going on these these escapades being
caught by batman handed over to the cops
and then you know escaping arkham again
and that kind of a thing it was a lot of
people looking at at the justice league
and saying like you never fix problems
all you ever do is keep them momentarily
at bay and so that's why they celebrated
magog and people like that now this
turned out to be the classic example be
careful what you asked for you just
might get it because humanity got
exactly what they wanted right they
wanted vigilante superheroes they got
vigilante superheroes and they don't
abide by laws and so what you saw was a
lot of like collateral damage people who
were actually living in fear from the
various superheroes that they were aware
of because these heroes and villains
would fight and even the heroes would
fight amongst themselves and there was
no concern with collateral damage or
anything like that now ultimately it led
to superman showing up and essentially
saving humanity from their own stupidity
but it was one of those really really
cool concepts right it was a great idea
in the kingdom come universe but that's
who this guy is now again following the
ending of kingdom come and seemingly the
earth kind of going into this new age
right this kind of grand utopia that
magog and all those guys were supposed
to have been sorted what's been going on
here what seems to have gone on here is
that with the multiverse being destroyed
during the last crisis event you know
the the dark multiverse story arc and
then it basically being restored at the
end of that thanks to like wonder woman
and the hands and so on and so forth
that a lot of the changes that have
previously been made in the multiverse
had reverted back to a previous state
now how far reaching this is for earth
22 we don't entirely know we don't know
if magog just killed superman and all
those guys we don't have an answer to
that here in the moment instead what we
end up doing is switching back to earth
zero now this is where i'm glad one of
you know a few of you guys chimed in and
it was like actually rob here's what's
going on with ellen scott because i'll
be honest with you guys i had totally
forgotten about dr manhattan and like
the justice society and all that kind of
stuff one because it took years for dc
to finally get around to tell that story
it took years for them to complete it
and it's been years since it was done
and so it's just kind of like it totally
escaped my memory
not even gonna lie but as a quick
refresher for you guys who were just
kind of like oh yeah how did that whole
thing go so one of the things to keep in
mind is that when dr manhattan
transitioned to the dc really multiverse
if we want to call it that um that what
he had done is that when the lantern
originally fell and alan scott was
supposed to have picked it up that he
moved it slightly out of the way and
alan scott never picked up the lamp and
then alan scott died he never became the
green lantern because he never became
the green lantern the justice society of
america was never formed and so the jsa
never existed it was really just kind of
jeff john's way of explaining why it is
that the dc superhero community was just
so screwed because there was nobody
there to show them a better way it's the
way that jeff johns depicted the jsa
back when he was initially writing it uh
and it's the way that he depicted the
jsa following the new 52 that it was
basically this idea that the jsa were
kind of the archetypes for the
superheroes as we know them batman
superman wonder woman aquaman the flash
all those guys in a lot of ways took
their moral lead from the actions of the
jsa themselves but without the jsa it
was just superheroes
just kind of being villains again that's
just one of those things but following
that the jsa has been around for a
little while they've been around since
then right so again that's kind of how
they ended up getting here now of course
you also have them operating as the
totality in the aftermath of the dark
multiversal crisis that what you got was
literally vandal savage and alan scott
and mr terrific and those guys basically
studying and
ensuring that like these multiversal
events don't necessarily happen again
they've obviously failed
[Laughter]
because things are kind of bad but for
their own individual story here again
kind of picking up from the last video
that we did that jade the daughter of of
alan scott was seemingly inside this old
jsa headquarters in gotham city and the
whole place had blown up and the
indication is that it matched the energy
signature of jade at least in appearance
but once they get here they find out
there's no no indication that she was
ever here so perhaps she was kidnapped
or something like that is kind of a
whodunit mystery or whatever it is but
essentially she's not the one
responsible for the destruction of this
place and so as a result of that it's
kind of the question of let's go find
her right let's go see what's going on
now there is a little bit of smack talk
that gets done where you have like
vandal savage basically talking about
the the son of alan scott who's like
right there right obsidian's like right
there and vandal savage because he's
because literally he lives up to his
namesake the dude's a savage
it's just kind of like you know there's
only one thing i've learned over my
entire lifetime alan scott and just this
all the years that i've been alive is
that children are nothing more than just
an annoyance so either get your son like
have your son get it together or have
your son get the hell out of here
because we don't have time for some
stupid kid who's concerned about his
sister missing you know alan scott
freaks out and attacks this guy now
here's the thing here's something to
know about alan scott is alan scott the
most popular character in dc comics no
but his fans are rabid son let me tell
you something man like talk crap about
alan scott and watch his fans come out
of the woodwork the fan like the fans of
alan scott they are die hard they won't
hear a word against him it's insane so
any instance where like alan scott does
something awesome like this where like
he channels his ring and just pummels
vandal savage they're like yeah alan
scott's amazing
i mean he is cool but it's just one of
those things where he's just got a super
hardcore fan base but again
transitioning yet again from the last
video that we did we jumped to roy
harper now one of the things that you
guys notice and one of the things that's
so crazy about this is roy harper is a
living black lantern that doesn't happen
but remember the only people who become
black lanterns are ones who are dead the
entire basis behind the black lantern
corps is to resurrect the dead that's
their whole idea right they're rings
that attach themselves to corpses and
they reanimate as what are by all
standards of measurement zombies right i
mean they operate based on the will of
necron right the the entity or the
master of the black lanterns if you want
to call it that but like at the end of
the day they're all basically just dead
people who are resurrected and walking
around and so that's the crazy thing is
because normally black lanterns are all
like emaciated and you know all decayed
and just wild looking that kind of stuff
not like literally not roy harper he
looks about as normal as a person does
look and so it's one of those things
where he kind of has a flashback too and
this is actually a great reference by
joshua williamson i love the way he
handled this he has a flashback to the
old green lantern green arrow comics
those who don't know the significance of
that there was a point in dc comics
where neither green lantern nor green
era was a was a well selling comic and
so instead of like doing the whole
backup features and all that kind of
stuff dc combined them and they
basically had them as like a team-up
comic which was hugely successful it was
immensely popular right like people
absolutely loved it during this little
bit of a thing here that what you had
was a kind of discussion between how
jordan and well at the time where harper
was known as speedy and the thing behind
this is he asked him like how does your
ring work and the responses of how
jordan is like it knows when i believe
in myself you know and the response to
speedy is like well i wish i had some of
that right some of that courage because
back then when comics were written back
in like the 70s the 60s 70s and so on
they focus more on the morality of
heroes and how heroes become better
versions of themselves as opposed to
comics now where it's just a series of
events right like that kind of a thing
where it's like a crisis event every
year because sales aren't going that
well like that kind of a thing uh and so
that's what hal jordan tells him like
let me ask you this right uh who's in
control right is it you or the boat like
what are you speedy a god of hammers
i know people are gonna draw that
parallel brother gonna be like the god
of hammers uh but that's what it is and
that's when when roy harper kind of
chimes in and says that's exactly what
it is right like i control the ring the
ring does not control me being able to
do that allows him to tap into the
ring's power the problem with this is
that as he does that and as he gains
more and more control over the ring one
of the things to always keep in mind is
that when it comes to the black lanterns
the rings influence you as much as you
influence the ring right so a way out is
a way in and so what this does is it
creates a stronger bond between the two
and then suddenly you have the ring that
basically just starts manifesting all
these beings who are essentially dead or
at least somehow tied into the whole
dark crisis event again it's very cloak
and dagger and it leaves us with more
questions and answers but roy harper
ends up seeing his daughter and is like
where is she right kind of talking to
the ring as much as he's talking to
himself and the ring somebody just
responds darkseid is and literally takes
over roy harper turns him into a black
lantern and sends him flying and like
flying out into space with no earthly
clue as to where it is that he's going
now this is where things get even
crazier because what you end up doing is
you basically switch over to uh to when
roy harper is like just kind of flying
out there right just just taking off and
it's kind of like what in the world
right like this military base sees it
happening and it's like what in the
world is going on because the only real
thing you get is simply just this voice
that says come to me my black lantern
and like that's it presumably it's
necron we don't entirely know for sure
but when all this is going down the
military is kind of like i mean should
we respond and captain adams shows up
and he's like no right don't worry about
that it's just this is one of those
things they don't have all of our
training we got other stuff we need to
focus about and so when he arrives on
the scene he's met by cameron chase and
so this discussion that happens between
the two is really really interesting
because what happens is that cameron
chase approaches him and is like we
actually need your help right like we
like we need you to jump on board with
us now that was also you know one of the
major cornerstones of captain adam the
captain adam was at one point a military
guy and in a lot of ways he kind of
looks at what's going on and just kind
of looks at the world as a whole and
it's kind of like i do my thing for the
military like i'm a servant of the
government in a lot of ways now it
doesn't mean that he will he will
absolutely obey everything the
government tells him the government and
the military are smart enough to know
not to piss off captain adam right i
mean literally
what could what would they do to kill it
there really isn't a whole lot they
could offer i mean the guy's just so
astronomically powerful but what he
talks about here is that he doesn't want
to join her he's like i'm retired right
i'm just kind of uh an advisor if
anything or i just kind of go on
missions for the government to sort of
do my thing but like that's basically it
right i'm i work for the military or i'm
an i'm an asp an element of the military
and that's really it and so that's when
she says that's not the nathan adam that
i used to know she says when you and i
were on that mission in markovia you
told me you'd never rest until you felt
the world was safe and he says that was
a long time ago chase a lot has happened
since then she says right but you and i
have never met before and that's the
true statement it's like they've never
met like she's never had a conversation
with him before and that's when she's
like who are you right like what earth
are you from because you're not from
this earth right like i've never met you
and yet you're telling me that we're
friends obviously you're not from here
and so that's when he's kind of like
like crap right like the oldest trick in
the book kind of thing you know and so
that's where you basically get this idea
that people from alternate earths
alternate universes are infiltrating
into the main dc universe which is one
of the reasons why infinite frontier and
dark crisis is so cool is because not
everything you see is what it appears to
be and not everybody you see is who they
appear to be and so she asked where's
the real captain adam and he simply says
i don't know but on my world you and i
were friends we don't even really get an
answer as to why it is that he's here
but he tells her you really don't
understand what's going on with the
multiverse and i simply know too much
and i cannot let you take me in and so
that's when he really like that's
literally the crazy thing here is he
starts to rip open his chest now what
this seems to indicate to be honest with
you guys what this seems to indicate is
this is earth 22 captain adam i'm not
going to swear by that and in fact i
haven't looked it up i just i want you
to imagine that it is i want to just
believe that it is i'm sure the answer
is out there i just don't want to look
it up yet but i feel like this would be
earth 22 captain adam because the way
he's dying that's the way he died in the
in the kingdom come universe literally
his chest was ripped open and it blew up
kansas it was crazy right like that's
one of the things that led to superman
basically stepping back in in the
kingdom come world but he says he'll
find out and he'll come for me i'm sorry
cameron and he simply just says darkseid
is and then detonates and literally just
blows up that entire area with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you all for watching and
i will catch you all later peace